[Musique]
note d'hier et d'aujourd'hui avec
williams un van williams bonsoir bonsoir
williams tu auteur compositeur
interprète et c'est un prof de sport qui
décèle en toi des aptitudes à la
créativité la danse la musique et le
chant alors que tu passais plus de temps
écouter et à réécouter des comédies
musicales plutôt que de t'entraîner sur
un stade
il a fallu que quelqu'un te signale que
pour toi la musique est donc la danse
était plus prometteur que le foot est ce
vrai oui c'est évidemment je dansais
plus sur le terrain que je ne jouais au
ballon effectivement ici on dit le chien
bull et moi juste et plus tôt chien
musique
donc effectivement très rapidement c'est
une prof dans mon lycée qui avait mis
une section danse dans le sport est
évidemment j'étais le premier séduit par
cette section
parce que j'avais déjà vu de la danse à
la télé et j'étais vraiment j'avais
vraiment envie de faire ce métier quand
j'ai vu certaines séries à la télé une
série en en particulier qui s'appelle
fame de parents ont-ils es tu grandis à
strasbourg entre la choucroute et les
cigognes sincèrement le cliché est ta
place c'était quoi le sortait plutôt
bien et mes parents à assumer totalement
aussi leurs lauriers parce qu'à la
maison on écoutait du gras max ont
écouté puis david martial et en même
temps on écoutait aussi du rôle de
l'église y a su et turner elvis presley
je me sentais bien on dans les deux
cultures
j'ai pas eu en plus on m'a pas fait
comprendre que je venais d'ailleurs des
premiers pas dans le métier tu vas faire
des scènes avec céline dion mariah carey
on se remarque et de quelle façon par le
travail par le travail j'ai commencé mes
écoles à strasbourg effectivement avec
une prof qui s'appelle lisa mickaël qui
était elle une prof complètement
inspirée qui avait aussi ce sens du
travail de la rigueur donc elle m'a
vraiment inculqué ça c'était l'idée
d'arriver avec quelque chose ou quand on
va faire des auditions
on sait qu'on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
d'avoir très très peur juste de se dire
gg le bagage qu'il faut pour pouvoir
rencontrer mon destin je répète souvent
ça parce que c'est vrai important que la
foi qu'on a dans ce qu'on veut faire
l'engagement qu'ont eue mais la joie
qu'on y met et le travail
l'année 2011 sera pour toi oui l'homme
sera d'une grande tournée avec michel
jonasz vous étiez venu chanter en
martinique on vous regarde sur scène on
se retrouve juste après quel beau
souvenir
mais bin autres
véhément
[Musique]
m
le
[Musique]
m
où
oh
mais
mais plus
mais vous aimez vous
[Musique]
rabat 12
j'aimerais magnifique halle
enfin pour le score
[Musique]
exact l'intitulé
tous cas
[Musique]
la main train de paiement
dulaney
fruit des témoins
[Musique]
comme jeanne meyer burger
le paquet
com
merci
c'est un beau métier sjtu les succès
m
[Musique]
je sais
elton john milton duke ellington miles à
john shannon ma personne aux cafés thés
jeune public aux managers
[Musique]
note d'hier et d'aujourd'hui williams
aval à l'instant aux côtés de michel
jonasz à l'olympia qui ont gardé
quelques souvenirs
un souvenir magique c'est un artiste que
j'ai découvert tout gamin j'étais dans
ma petite chambre dans mon appartement
dans mon hlm à cronenbourg à strasbourg
et j'ai découvert cet artiste à travers
un cousin qui est de martinique j'écoute
et je trouvais ça très très beau la
façon d'aider l'écrivez de la façon d'un
swing et ça me parlait beaucoup et
d'avoir la possibilité de travailler
avec lui des années plus tard c'est
valve a cédé rêve qui se réalise c'est
là la force de croire en ses rêves
michel 6 quelques fidèles et on s'envoie
des petits textos de temps en temps et
on se tient au courant de ce qu'on fait
il m'a présenté un ami à lui qui
s'appelle anna golstein pour faire les
des textes de mon premier album
mais effectivement c'est une personne
que je garde chaudement dans mon coeur
et ma appris aussi que la rigueur le
travail parce que lui c'est quelqu'un de
méticuleux il est pointilleux surtout la
lumière sur scène le son ce qu'on fait
au niveau des chorégraphies
c'est un perfectionniste on allait bien
ensemble on a dix ans donc on arrive
donc à se faire des amis dans la musique
oui on peut se faire des amis ça dépend
toujours de se comportent nous en nous
ce qu'on ce qu'on a envie de montrer
d'eux de nous l'image qu'on qu'on
renvoie c'est une image qu'on a en nous
et si on veut qu'on nous voie de telle
façon et on nous verra de telle façon
moi j'ai décidé depuis très longtemps
d'être celui que je suis comme
aujourd'hui intègre et avec une certaine
vérité dans dans mais dans l'engagement
et dans ce que j'ai envie de dire de
faire c'est sûr que quand tu as
spectacle se termine
si une grande famille à chaque fois
c'est des familles c'est par moment donc
il ya beaucoup d'émotion il ya beaucoup
de choses qui se passe pendant la
période de travail la pensée par des
spectacles de ce spectacle se termine on
part sur d'autres aventures il ya des
personnes qu'on garde chaque fois des
petites personnes qu'on garde comme ça
d'un spectacle à l'autre mais c'est
l'essai on est des gens du voyage il y
aurait donc laventure jonas à partir de
moment là tu est sur les rails pour
d'autres spectacles mais également pour
la sortie d'un premier album premier
album qui s'appelle chavirer connotation
un peu latine soul en français que j'ai
fait avec un garçon capelle flic missir
parce que j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer son papa les hommes et sierre
qui était le bras droit des libertés et
donc les oem avait rencontré dans un
spectacle après un stack de jonas avec
michel drucker et donc il est venu
naturellement peut dire qu'il avait
envie de m'aider c'est en plus celui là
des rares personnes qui l'avaient aidé
c'était balavoine donc ce n'est pas
n'importe qui et donc il m'a confié à
son fils philippe et on a travaillé
ensemble d'arrache-pied travail et
travail des chansons j'ai fait les
premières parties de lara fabian j'avais
quelques émissions mais je pense je
pense que l'univers a voulu que que je
fasse autre chose et que je retrouve
vraiment mes origines musicales et mes
racines
un projet un album en préparation par
est il exactement donc cet album lui il
est totalement en anglais quand je
chante enlevé je suis je suis en accord
avec moi-même puisque tous les
spectacles que tu fais tu chantes
toujours en anglais tout ce que tu fais
du travail à travers le monde et tu
chantes en anglais donc ton album
logiquement pourrait aussi être comme ça
donc j'ai dit ah ben oui je vais le
faire comme ça donc ils et soul funk ce
que je suis dit collaborer avec un
garçon qui s'appelle patrick rault fait
c'est un garçon plein d'imagination 4
fait aussi de la musique pour le cinéma
donc on sait bien compris parce que
l'album il et il est très imagé très
scénique ça c'était important pour moi
de le retranscrire de rentrer dans ma
musique
pour cette émission tu as choisi
d'écouter calvin harris on se retrouve
juste
[Musique]
note d'hier et d'aujourd'hui avec
williams en valeur c'est frais c'est
fleury calvin harris pharrell williams
on devient api tout de suite c'est ce
que tu aimes
oui parce que dans ce dans ce clip ses
couleurs la place de plein de plein de
couleurs plein de cette très pétillant
on est juste dans quelque chose qui nous
prend et on est on est on navigue et on
part dans la dans le dans le pour ce
voyage avec les artistes j'aime quand
les veaux les artistes nous font voyager
si toi c'est la comédie musicale
effectivement les codes du musicale
américaine parce qu'on parle de celles
là elles sont sûres exacte des happy end
et on est dans la joie dans la légèreté
bien sûr que la vie elle a une densité
et il ya des fois des choses un peu
lourde mais elle est chargée aussi de
plein de nuances plein couleurs et les
comme musicale l on se l oms cette
force-là de nous de nos amis d'une
couleur à l'autre d'une émotion à
l'autre nous faire voyager et je trouve
que ça c'est la magie de déco musicale
cantat sont bien les crétins évidemment
avec un beau livre et elle nous amène à
nous envoler dans des bandes et dans des
mondes complètement féerique ne williams
aval
évoquons maintenant les choses en
musique ton premier souvenir musical mon
premier souvenir musical basset fame
[Musique]
pour rappel sur cette phrase de la prof
qui dit ici vous allez payer avec la
sueur ça se paie le travail se paye avec
la sueur alors moi je suis pas pour être
dans la douleur parce que je trouve que
le la vie c'est seydou plutôt que de
douleur il ya plus de douceur moi je
suis plus dans la douceur on fait les
choses avec avec amour et joie et
détente
on n'a pas besoin d'être tendue pour
créer ou pour réaliser
je trouve qu'on comptera quand on est
relâché les choses se passent beaucoup
plus facilement et c'est beaucoup plus
digeste
williams est vrai la chanson qui te fait
pleurer à sas et total prise
[Musique]
ce qui me plaît c'est que c'est
l'harmonie des voix ça veut dire qu'avec
toutes ces voix on n'entend qu'une et
c'est ça exprime bien le la musique et
la vie on a tous besoin des uns et des
autres et dans une chorale si on ne
s'écoute pas leurs bas c'est une
cacophonie petit à une belle partition
quand elle est écrite avec harmonie tout
se passe de façon très simple la chanson
qui te met en joie instant tonnes
d'ailerons
[Musique]
un corner qu'est ce que j'aime cette
chanteuse
quelle classe quelle beauté quelle
quelle histoire quelle présence qu'elle
de cesser c'est une artiste majestueuse
diana ross et cette chanson elle est
pour moi symbole de voilà 2 1 pén art
quand je gère yves je suis là je donne
de la joie et il ya des pouilles est de
du soleil partout de la lumière par tous
les autres chanter ça c'est voilà ce
qu'on écoute cette chanson c'est ça
donne vraiment envie de vivre encore
plus la chanson qui te dévoile le plus
c'est love l ovi et de nat king cole
qu'ils ont été tués
l'amour
jack guez
elle dit tout cette chanson le savoir
dans de garder dans son salon ça sert à
rien de le partager ça a beaucoup plus
d'impact et de le partager avec les plus
jeunes les moins jeunes elle avec les
personnes âgées de se partager la
connaissance c'est quelque chose
d'important et ça passe par l'amour love
la chanson que tu aurais aimé écrire
[Musique]
soit
c'est
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson tirée de ce film c'est
roméo juliette des temps modernes
aujourd'hui on est toujours pareil on
est toujours dans cette problématique de
la différence on n'accepte pas que
quelqu'un d'autre soit différente nous
on a l'impression que ça va être lui le
responsable de l'autre malheur donc
cette chanson elle a beaucoup de
symboles et maria c'est comme une prière
aujourd'hui tu as choisi de regarder
human de ryan baumann on regarde le clip
ensemble on en parle juste après
[Musique]
de rome
bush
cambodgien
mais
que nous mais aussi je sais
au lieu de six
naji ben ali tout symbolique
mais johnny
non
bon ben hodges rain
[Musique]
vous sentez vous l'âme
et
sa mère
bingo
hélas
m
avant lui
mais à
glassman ligne dans la semaine la nuque
harmonix
naf trouve en amont ni cube
gobeil monde
donc bravo
[Musique]
nous sommes évoquées
sow
la bomba
amendé
demain
big ben
st
on est curieux
m
note d'hier et d'aujourd'hui avec
williams aval organes bodemann pourquoi
parce que dans cette chanson il dit
plein de choses qui me parle aussi un
jeu je sais ce physique
ce physique imposant comme ça ce garçon
qu'il a et qui dit qu'effectivement il
est qu'un humain quoi il y à un humain
il fait le maximum pour que les choses
puissent avancer puisse se faire
mais il n'est pas responsable du malheur
du voisin ou de ce qui peut arriver
il a sa part de réhabiliter dans sa
propre vie et en fonction de ça si
chacun a sa propre part de
responsabilité dans sa petite maison
effectivement les choses on allait mieux
et elle et c'est une belle chanson elle
est chargée de belles émotions et j'aime
moi les choses quand elles sont simples
à l'écran un hommage aux plus grands
artistes de la soul
c'était une envie que j'avais justement
de rendre hommage à toutes ces personnes
qui m'ont inspiré donc ça va de jolo des
titres qui sont juste jouer piano voix
où effectivement on est juste dans le
dans le temps dans le squelette de la
chanson est donc là on peut pas se
cacher derrière des arrangements de
violon de cuivre ont ni un piano à queue
et une voix parce que j'ai envie dans ce
spectacle de raconter l'histoire de ces
chansons l'histoire de ces artistes
l'histoire de ce peuple
ok on était les champs de coton et
finalement on arrive à faire que des
peuples que les blancs et noirs sont
ensemble et c'est grâce à l'ouverture
d'esprit et se dire que la musique elle
se partagent toujours la même le même
propos mais ça n'a pas été évident
évident va te voir aux côtés de julie by
trees en première partie de lara fabian
et tu écris tu la propre comédie
musicale new jack times raconte j'ai
commencé à écrire des chansons avec un
garçon s'appelle obame et un autre
garçon qui s'appelle josé et on a on a
écrit des chansons pour ce spectacle
c'est en anglais c'était important de
d'aller au bout de cette démarche parce
que effectivement la création pour moi
est une part très importante dans ma vie
je
je crée avec un bruit de un son que
j'entends dans la rue un klaxon des
voitures ou des fois j'étais ce matin
j'étais dans ma douche et j'entends des
lots qui faisaient tac tac tac tac tac
tac c'est une chanson voilà tout
m'inspire
et puis il y aura mine de rien un retour
vers les antilles on va devoir en
collaboration avec pascal vallot pour
une autre comédie musicale solitude la
marronne et puis sur scène avec josé
versol effectivement josé c'est une très
belle rencontre très belle rencontre
parce qu'on se rencontre à la darpa dans
un spectacle que ma cousine christiane
phare aux avait organisé et donc je suis
venu lui donner un coup de main faire ce
spectacle pour les personnes âgées
ça me plaisait pas ce que c'était nos
anciens c'est c'était important d'être
là pour eux et donc je vais dit bien
fait venir aussi des artistes locaux et
l appeler josé josé était étaient
présents et on s'est rencontrés on a eu
un coup de foudre artistique et ça
donnait ce spectacle autour de la
mazurka à l'atrium une belle rencontre
parce que finalement je suis un peu son
ange gardien dans ce spectacle et est
lui aussi puisque rim a fait revenir au
pays natal grande aventure on va se
retrouver sur scène nous y sommes une
présentation de swinging life autre
comédie musicale
[Musique]
le temps
m
là
[Musique]
eh ben
le cas
les bras
[Musique]
note d'hier et d'aujourd'hui avec
williams aval swinging life une comédie
musicale complicité d'artistes paraît-il
faisant partie de la distribution de
nombreux spectacles musicaux là vous y
allé avec avec le coeur c'est obligé oui
c'était super parce que finalement on
vous faisait découvrir au public des
comme juste qu'elle ne savait pas
l'occasion de voir en france et nous on
prenait beaucoup de plaisir parce que on
switcher d'un personnage à l'autre mots
à mon ange était une un travesti à un
moment j'étais un maquereau un autre
moment j'étais un peu à dragueur donc
c'était c'était intéressant à voir ses
différentes casquettes mise en scène par
valérie rodrigues important de le citer
parce que c'est un garçon formidable
nouveau des images de la répétition
tu le disais faut le souligner c'est
beaucoup de travail le travail ne donne
cette liberté après sur scène on ne
réfléchit plus on ne se regarde plus
chanter comme des fois on peut voir où
on se regarde pas danser regarde pas
joué on est on est justement et donc on
incarne totalement et du coup là c'est
la place à la liberté
et puis chanter danser c'est un travail
bien en amont une certaine hygiène de
vie je suppose évidemment c'est comme un
sportif c'est comme un sportif en tout
cas je moi je le prends comme ça j'ai
une certaine énergie sur scène qui me
demande d'être suffisamment reposé pour
être au maximum et chaque public a le
droit d'avoir le même spectacle le
public d'hier et de demain et d'après
demain alors par la danse la musique
pour voir william st val heureux il ya
d'autres choses qui t'anime la famille
ça c'est ma passion et la cuisine donc
j'aime cuisiner pour mon épouse et mes
enfants et j'aime cuisiner pour mes amis
et pour les personnes que je peux
découvrir c'est voilà mais mais mais
mais passion et de prendre du temps le
temps de vivre le temps de justement
d'avoir l'inspiration mais si tu devais
parler au petit william hill est à
strasbourg
il est haut comme trois pommes qu'est ce
que tu lui dirai continue de rêver reste
dans cette joie kita qui t'anime et qui
te caractérise bien
elle soit dans cette notion de partage
et n'oublie pas qu'il ya toujours
quelqu'un à côté de toi qui a besoin de
toi comme tu as besoin de lui
williams continue de rêver et continue
de nous faire rêver aussi à bientôt
merci beaucoup qu'un pas
[Musique]